in telling us in the first episode of
Yellowjackets just how bad things will
get before the team makes it out of the
Wilderness the show set itself up to not
be about the things that happen but how
the characters react to those things the
first season left us with a lot of
questions about what those things would
be and the question of what happened to
Shauna's first baby was high on that
list I suppose if you had told me that
they would pull a fake out I probably
wouldn't have liked that idea but I
think they managed to pull off a Twist
that adds to whatever comes next without
taking anything away I had a really
strange experience while I was watching
that I think is worth mentioning though
after my weekly ritual of getting tired
of refreshing the Paramount Plus app to
see if the episode had shown up yet I
clicked over to the Press site where I
noticed that the episode 7 photos were
posted that gave away the title of the
next episode which seemed to confirm my
suspicions that there was no way the
baby would survive Vibe then as I got to
the point in the episode where Shauna is
holding this large robust baby boy my
wife came into my office and asked for
my help with something that she said
wouldn't take very long so for the next
15 minutes while I was doing that I
cycled through the hole it has to be a
dream so what are they trying to do what
are the reasons behind doing it that way
and when I came back and rewounded a bit
and started from the beginning of that
scene it seemed pretty obvious with the
cut to Black and the way that they were
all smiling like they were in Jackie's
death dream that it was some sort of
unreality the point of this is not to
say that anyone should have seen what
was happening but rather that even
feeling ninety percent sure it wasn't
real didn't take away from the emotional
impact and the fact that it wasn't real
to anyone else except Shauna who dreamed
it doesn't change the way that she felt
in the closing shot when faced with the
reality of what happened I'll come back
around to that at the end but I think
that all ties in nicely with the idea
that none of what they experience has to
be real in order to have an effect on
them given the situation people look for
answers and explanations when they're
presented with something that's
inexplicable and that provides fertile
ground for the writers as they continue
to fill in the gaps between the two
timelines the answer to what happened to
shawna's Baby is cut and dry and it's
nice to put that one to bed but then I
do have to wonder how the Lottie
followers will make sense of their
failed bloodletting ritual or what might
still be to come since adult Lottie went
back to cutting her Palm in the present
daytime line just a couple of episodes
back as far as Yellowjackets episodes go
this was a pretty straightforward one
but there's still a lot to talk about
thankfully it ends with the whole band
back together at lottie's compound which
I think should Elevate things from here
on out to get there we had to get
through Shauna and her family being
called to the police station I'm sure
this isn't where that that story ends
but it does feel like we'll get a
reprieve from it and all things
considered it ended on a high note Jeff
jamming out to NWA in the parking lot
Cali running with the idea that Shawna
planted when she said it would have been
better if she had sex with officer
syracusa and a really great look inside
shawna's thought processes as she breaks
down under questioning about Adam in
that you really see how her past affects
her present when she says you have a kid
that you don't want to save a marriage
that you got into out of guilt and shame
and you just you can't really let
yourself love either of them this is
probably the most honest thing anyone
has said in this show and of course the
detective thinks it's all part of some
elaborate plan rather than being a
sincere confession I guess in a weird
way that might actually help her in the
long run obviously she's leaving the
part about stabbing Adam out of her
story but she is saying some rather
incriminating things that she probably
shouldn't but but he also has reason not
to believe her because of the Randy
situation at the motel what seems more
important is that what she says here
ties in with what happens to her younger
self at the end of the episode and
explains a lot about who she is in the
present day timeline she's saying that
being afraid that she'll lose Cali or
Jeff the same way she lost her baby is
why she's never been good at loving them
even though she never wanted to be a mom
she doesn't believe that she started out
a bad person and of course she does love
her family she loves them despite
herself but she feels like she's
incredibly bad at it seeing her have the
dream of what could have been with the
Wilderness baby and pairing that with
this Revelation about how she sees
herself now sinks the two timelines
together Cali's invoking Matt's weird
ass balls will probably buy them some
time although it's probably also going
to ensure that he doubles down in coming
after them I'm not sure if the phone
call from Ty and the way she decided to
take Jeff advice to go to lotties where
some of the episode's finest moments but
I think it does make sense for her to
want to be there when she finds out
everyone's coming back together if for
no other reason than being with the
people who understand the thing that
made her the person she just described
in that interview out in Ohio things are
a little uncomfortable especially for
Van she explains that she talked to the
other Ty and tells her that she said
we're not supposed to be here I'm not a
hundred percent sure that's all that
happened but I guess if Ty doesn't
remember then it's between van and her
altar either way her reaction to being
surprised at the idea of us referring to
them makes sense after all Ty is still
married to Simone she's not wrong to
keep her distance and we see her do that
throughout their interactions Misty's
call from the kitchen phone at lottie's
gets them moving in that direction and
across the board everyone seems
completely surprised that Lottie is
running a wellness business rather them
being locked up in an institution in
Switzerland speaking of Misty it didn't
take her long to warm up to the
attention she gets at the compound
because she knows Nat and Lottie her
emptying her pockets on arrival was
super fun and it's also super fun that
I'm not sure if those are things that
she always carries around with her or if
it's a specific kit that she put
together for her Mission with Walter I'm
incredibly curious to find out what the
messages he sent to her say but we'll
probably have to wait for a while before
she sees them Lottie isn't happy to see
her at first but comes around and asks
her to stay we learned later that her
reaction wasn't about feelings she has
for Misty personally but that her
showing up fits into fears that she's
having about the Past coming back to her
I don't want to spend too much time on
this but once again her visit with the
psychiatrist was a little off it's the
same actor playing the role but this
time we don't see her face at all last
time I thought it was odd that they
chose to add the detail that this was a
replay placement therapist rather than
the regular person she sees there were a
lot of theories that were thrown around
about what might be going on with that
and a lot of criticism about the advice
she gave her and while this encounter
didn't take any of those ideas off the
table it felt different in that it
focused things back on Lottie not
showing her face here is definitely
another choice that makes the meeting
suspicious but now it feels more like
maybe this is all in lottie's head or
just a way to show that she's losing her
grip on reality it's something that'll
be in the back of my mind but not nearly
as interesting as what Lottie actually
says by this point the idea of Lottie
only being an opportunistic cult leader
preying on her followers is a little
hard to square just as her younger self
seems more reluctant to take power than
it seemed like she would have been at
the end of the last season the adult
does appear to want to help people
rather than just exploiting them she
doesn't appear to be completely honest
or absolutely pure in her intentions but
she's not entirely predatory either in
relation to what we see with Shauna at
the police station it becomes clear that
what Lottie does is more of a reaction
to the things that happened in her life
essentially a trauma response rather
than her being a cult leader in the
traditional sense in hindsight this
makes perfect sense based on the themes
at play but the way they presented the
character at the end of last season made
it seem like there might be something
different going on with her earlier in
the season we saw that even though she
uses the symbol and some of her rituals
resemble what happened in the woods she
has regrets about what they did out
there just like everyone else does
what's more is that she tells her
psychiatrist that she's not worried that
she's ill but that she's never been ill
in other words what she experienced back
then was real rather than symptoms of
her mental illness Travis Natalie and
Misty all showing up at the same time
feels like the power of that place the
god of that place is sending them to
show her that it's real she says they
did Terrible Things in its name when
they were out there and now she realizes
that they brought it back with them this
is all influenced by the session that
she had with Nat in the last episode
which is having a profound effect on
both of them and the show finally found
a clever way to make Lisa a little more
compelling after the session that is at
a place where she's essentially seeing
things as they are instead of how she
chose to twist them but at the same time
she's somewhat overcompensating in
blaming herself for what happened she
explains this to Lisa when she tells her
she should stay away from her because
she ruins people and that she's poison
she says that she killed Travis the only
person she loved and the only person who
knew her and she's been blaming it on
Lottie but now she believes it was her
own fault Lisa gives her her fish to
take care of and a way to get her to get
ready to take care of herself which
works well with what we've seen between
these two because even though Nat has
been making a mess of her own life she
was capable of giving Lisa some sound
advice when she asked why she forgave
her for stabbing her in the face she
says suffering is inevitable and only by
meeting it with compassion can we begin
to grow which is probably something that
she learned from Lottie it's clever
because she's using things she picked up
from them to point out what they haven't
been able to do in their own lives based
on the lasting effects of their time in
the wilderness this spills over into her
interaction with Misty as well you see
her bring up Walter and Misty's reaction
to that and realize that he presented
himself as a character that was offering
exactly what she was looking for
accepting her for who she is and she
wasn't able to let him in and that makes
Nat ending their conversation with the
question we're all like this aren't we
perfect this episode is about Shauna and
what she goes through deserves most to
Bar attention but now that we're nearing
the end of the season I do find it very
promising that we get such important
Revelations right along with that that
feel complementary in a season where the
adults have largely been split up this
is all pointing at how much they can
offer each other as they come back
together while at the same time we see
the divisions between them solidifying
in the 96 timeline before we get to
shawna's really intense labor we take a
brief flashback to the before times
which is kind of fun because that's not
something we normally do and we see them
in health class and the team's brief
education on childbirth that no one pays
attention to except for Misty although
this won't be enough to help and in the
end I suppose it doesn't matter because
the baby never had a chance to survive a
natural birth in these conditions in
that way Misty's freezing up seem to be
more about reminding us that Crystal had
just died and that keeping that secret
was taken a toll on her it also provides
a chance for a killer to step up and
take Center Stage for a while and a
chance for Lottie to give Misty a pep
talk that brings her back around
although she refers to the baby here as
our baby which is a little bit creepy it
also sets up another dream sequence from
coach Ben imagining what his life would
have been like with his boyfriend Paul
this time they play charades and they're
in a room that is a combination of the
cabin and his apartment after seeing so
many of these which all just seem to
show the deterioration of his mental
state it's hard to see them as anything
other than the setup for the end of his
story there were popular theories that
this might be something that would
reignite his will to survive but as you
see the cabin start to take over his
fantasy land that makes it seem unlikely
that he'll ever leave there two other
things stand out as being important in
shaping the aftermath of this tragic
event the first is that we see Lottie
try to help come for Shauna in a way
that I think shows some of her personal
limits in the previous episode Shauna
made it clear that she was freaked out
by lottie's interest in her baby and she
freaked out when she woke up to her
whispering to her belly the fact that
she tries to touch Shawna while she's in
the middle of all this pain makes me
think that she has a blind spot when it
comes to being able to take the
temperature of whatever it is that's
happening around her sure this is an
intense situation and you can't expect
people to be at their best but this
sequence stood out as her being
blatantly out of touch with how Shauna
feels about her in that moment the
second thing is that Travis is the one
that initiates their impromptu
bloodletting ritual this makes more
sense in a way everyone in that room
that's never delivered a baby is
somewhat powerless to change the outcome
of what's happening it's believable that
they might try for a spiritual solution
or a supernatural one if you prefer as
this is starting to be normal in the
group anyway way the thing about him
being the one to start at this time
though is that the baby still dies so it
becomes a test of faith rather than
something that reinforces their beliefs
I think that as things get worse their
desire to believe will increase they'll
get more irrational about it so I wonder
if this will solidify lottie's role as
being the special one there's still a
chance that something else will happen
that they'll look at as a reward for
what they did here specifically spilling
blood but it would have to be something
big considering how crushed everyone is
about the baby and I do want to stress
that this was a devastatingly painful
episode for shawna's character and one
where Sophie nelise delivers a
career-defining performance while there
are moments of hope that things might
turn around the birth is pretty much
doomed from the beginning I don't know
any more about the birthing process than
the people in that cabin but the
internet tells me that if the placenta
comes out first the baby will almost
always die short of an emergency
C-section since it's no longer getting
oxygen and the mother's chances of
survival are also very low with that in
mind and Ty's declaration that she lost
so much blood I think of the dream
sequence as another near-death
experience as I mentioned when you go
back and look at it again it certainly
resembles Jackie's death dream and I
know that the subtitles say it's Misty
but I agree with the people who were
posting that it sounds like it's
Jackie's voice saying Shauna when she
first wakes up into it again the fact
that it's a dream doesn't take away from
what happens and I actually think it'll
turn out to be very important it's all
very difficult to watch knowing how
things end especially the turn where she
begs the baby to latch and the way she
says it's you and me kid it's you and me
against the whole world there we get to
see her experience Joy when he finally
starts feeding only to have that ripped
away first in the dream where her fear
about about losing him and her regret
over eating Jackie manifesting her
seeing the others eating him and then
again when she wakes up and finds out
the truth confronted with that it's not
surprising that she chooses denial once
more I have to say that the young actor
delivered that in a way that was
absolutely haunting I didn't have a
strong reaction to the cannibalism scene
here because that was the moment I knew
for sure that it was a dream based on
the Creator's assurances that they
wouldn't eat the baby but I did have a
strong reaction to the closing shot we
get to see the grief on each of the
girls faces that were there to witness
that and then we see each of them move
out of the frame so that Sean is all
alone in the final seconds with her loss
and impending sorrow beyond the
performance in the gut punch of the
death I keep going back to Lottie saying
that the baby would change everything I
think this changes things in a way that
isn't immediately apparent because this
was something that kept them all
together in their desperate situation it
was something to look forward to not
just for Shauna but for the group as a
whole clearly lottie's thought was that
the birth would bring them all together
and give them something to survive for
so now that the thing is gone what are
they left with I think the fear of the
people closest to her bleeding through
into Shauna's dream is a sign of where
her head will be and her dislike of
Lottie will continue to grow in a coming
split and that is the only one you could
see taking her side without question Tai
is generally on her side but her
allegiances are split because of van and
in this episode we saw her give in and
start to try to do the chanting which
seemed like it kind of worked when they
were lost in the snowstorm Javi also
seems to feel a certain way about Lottie
but he's barely even speaking so it's
hard to say where he would stand and I
don't know who else that leaves except
maybe coach Ben but more important than
how people might take sides is how
they're going to react to this insane
the traumatic experience on top of
everything else that's happening I
thought this was the best episode of the
season so far partially because we saw
all the adults come back together and
there's a lot of anticipation about
what's going to happen there but I think
we're seeing the opposite happen in the
woods and I think that means that things
are going to take a dark turn and I
think that is a great place to leave
things please like this video If you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon
thank you